stéphane caillet merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur rt france au vu des
chiffres la situation sanitaire mérite
t'elle à nouveau tour de vis selon vous
un certain nombre de départements vont
passer en alerte maximale dès demain à
priori a indiqué le porte parole du
gouvernement
on constate depuis une petite semaine
qu'il y a en effet une augmentation du
nombre de cas mais je ne compte pas
tellement les cas de l'écart positif je
compte plutôt les cas de maladie parce
que ce sont ceux là qui ont vraiment du
sens sur le plan de l'épidémiologie et
les données que nous avons à disposition
sont essentiellement le nombre quotidien
de nouvelles hospitalisations qui montre
une augmentation en effet depuis
quelques jours et le nombre quotidien de
nouvelle admission en réanimation
effectivement depuis quelques jours on
voit une reprise de l'épidémie mais qui
n'a rien à voir avec l'explosion à
laquelle nous avons assisté fin mars
début avril
alors faut-il resserrer la vis je pense
que il serait déjà bien de réussir à
faire appliquer très correctement les
mesures qui sont édictées avant d'en
ajouter d'autres c'est les gestes
barrières par exemple les gestes
barrière c'est surtout le masque
j'entendais à l'instant l'ancien premier
ministre edouard philippe de discuter du
mas le masque reste la première mesure
de prévention
malgré tout ce que l'on dit on d une
chose et son contraire
c'est un virus respiratoires
essentiellement respiratoires et le
masque reste la principale mesure de
prévention
à condition qu'il soit bien porté et là
encore il ya de nombreuses insuffisances
c'est quand même quelque chose et qu'il
faut répéter parce que c'est la vérité
on a l'impression que beaucoup de gens
portent leur masque dès l'instant où ils
sont en public et ils savent qu'ils sont
observés
et puis dès l'instant où on se retrouve
en petit comité entre soi et bien le
masque a tendance à tomber et toute la
ccsa
blême et on a on a dénoncé les soirées
les soirées entre adolescents et de
jeunes et on sait très bien que il ya
une concentration humaine dans des
locaux exigus sans ventilation et à ce
moment là il n'y a plus du tout de
masque puis à c est justement vous
parlez de ces fêtes des jeunes le
couvre-feu
est-ce que c'est suffisant selon vous
tel qu'il est mise en place aujourd'hui
c'est à dire à partir de 21h est ce que
disent nos morts ce serait mieux quel
est votre regard sur ce couvre-feu
hamon avait 21h c'est suffisant 19h
serait vraiment invivable ça
consisterait à mettre tout les laisse ou
les soirées à l'arrêt c'est 21h c'est
déjà bien mais est ce que on a des
moyens de les faire respecter ce
couvre-feu
tout à l'heure il n'est pas suffisamment
respecté aujourd'hui la 2d vous d'après
ce que vous observez nous n'avons
honnêtement nous n'avons pas les moyens
de le faire respecter suffisamment et je
sais très bien par où et dire parce que
des caves ont été rapportées qui vient
encore beaucoup d'entorses à au respect
du couvre-feu est bon et je reviens
toujours à ccc soirée parce qu'il ya eu
plusieurs travaux à ce sujet ces soirées
notre âme a notamment entre étudiants où
il n'y a pas du tout du masque il n'y a
pas du tout le port de masques alors
comment ça arrange t-il pour éviter de
se retrouver dans la rue et d'éviter
d'être surpris je ne sais pas mais le
couvre-feu manifestement ne suffit pas
tout à fait bon mais il est encore un
petit peu tôt il faut attendre encore
quelques jours mais atteint que si d'ici
à la fin de la semaine
la l'augmentation du nombre d'admissions
en réanimation et d'hospitalisation
continue à elle être confirmée là il
faudra quand même réfléchir et à une
adaptation des mesures est juste
peut-être une adaptation des méthodes de
contrôle
justement à strasbourg quelle est la
situation à ce qu'on se rapproche du
seuil d alerte
la situation à strasbourg heureusement
tout se passe bien on est dans une zone
d'assez faible circuit
l'action du virus le secteur hospitalier
est très loin d'être saturé et la
situation on peut dire que ledit à
strasbourg et contrôlée elle n'a rien à
voir avec ce qui se passe par exemple en
ile de france et vous vos équipes
comment pouvez-vous faire comment elles
sont prêtes à faire face à une seconde
vague massive comment ça se passe
massive peut être pas mais une
augmentation franche du nombre
d'hospitalisations et du nombre
d'admissions en réanimation
oui certainement merci beaucoup
stéphane guillet d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
médecins infectiologues au chru de
strasbourg